an alien vs. predator motorcycle and
quit peeing in my sink oh I I guess I
guess you're supposed to be in the sink
Vsauce Kevin here this is mind blow
Toyota's window to the world concept is
a multimedia car window that allows you
to draw objects that integrate with the
world zoom in on things in the distance
and define passing objects cross to wear
a cooling object just put on these
air-conditioned clothes
they feature small fans that cool down
body heat by evaporating sweat the
concept itself isn't new but the demand
is increasing to include air-conditioned
beds and seat cushions these
construction workers are going to need
more than a cushion if they fall off
this thing
it's a plank path being built along
cliffs in South China's Hunan Province
the workers live on the mountain as they
work on the path at several hundred
meters long but only one meter wide with
no guardrails Colonel Sanders evangelion
um okay milk clothes no really these
clothes are made of a fabric called milk
yarn which is processed from substandard
milk that would otherwise be thrown out
so it's considered environmentally
friendly and it feels almost like silk
milk silk to recycle CDs just create a
carpet like this one in Paris it's an
art installation called waste landscape
and it's made up of 65,000 discarded CDs
this robot bird flies by flapping its
wings and it's modeled after a seagull
it's called smart bird and it's
extremely lightweight and marks an
incredible achievement in aerodynamics
now look at the color of these hearts
they're obviously exactly the same right
now when we remove the background
they're different with their contextual
backgrounds the hearts look to be the
same color but when we place them on a
colorless background we can see it's an
illusion and they're obviously not the
same color eight-foot albino can fish
and finally from the man who brought you
the Mega Man and Final Fantasy 7 short
films here's an epic street fighters
stop-motion animation
I'll better leave you with the riddle
I can sizzle like bacon I'm made with an
egg I have plenty of backbone but lack a
good leg I peel layers like onions but
still remain whole I could be long like
a flagpole yet fit in a hole what am i
there's one movie one anime and three
video game references in this video the
first person to name all five will be
our genius of the week so good luck and
as always thanks for watching